welcome to this video playing ha gay
from spain one of the most frequent
opponents 18 games with 14 wins and four
losses I lost the most recent one when
I'm splayed the white side of some song
Lord Stonewall set up I was quite
frustrating that's but it's it's it's
why not be six you know who is playing
b3 all the time why is he not playing b6
at least it's got a pretty high rating
for his standard I spin on 25 once
that's really high him yeah he's not
playing I don't know why okay well
that's basically advanced b3 b6 well not
that it's any any bad but ok so the the
double fianchetto not an opening that
promises white a huge advantage of any
advantage at home but at least this is a
very solid afam Knight to d7 yeah of
course can do that
why is playing really quickly yeah I
want one tonight ultimately from e3 25
this is going 91 this is not something
great but it is ok we can play that
really yeah c'mon this is the case of
moose move first and think later I'm
going to do that anyway but am i winning
material here not really am isn't this
unfair ok um yeah I have to take the
Queen I guess Bishop takes e4 is a
ridiculous kind of sacrifice I guess now
I guess ok so is this something rip
deform us and I can always go back
there's nothing baby night f4 is an idea
that irritates like a bit yeah in fact
it should irritate them a bit to d5 form
n to e6
yeah I'm going here g5 is a good a good
square okay
hmm i'm not sure how to play it like
with g4 and h4 one or h4 h5 this kind of
business
yeah g5 is designed to attack his pawn
structure and gain more space should I
play f3 first maybe mf3 after play um do
I have to play it come on taking e for
away from him probably just make some
sense yet the Stratton snow to take her
cakes King takes 95 takes pawn takes d6
hang so he's some only having ok
somewhat somewhat tough choices and what
about this yeah ff4 is ridiculous yeah
this gives up tons of tons of squares
but i can go h 5 ER after the capture
gauge one keeping keeping pressure on
Jack yeah take it home after Knight
takes that's f4 with the fork okay so we
took it with this night g5 let's f for
em and I'm getting h7 this is a real
power play I guess well yes he will has
have problems all the time rook h5 there
is night f41 fortunately
okay double here on there is no way to
keep the porn yeah that's really
unfortunate
I just want to double them 95 rook h1
I'm threatening roop g6 that's that's
really difficult to play I mean this is
a huge position for wine
having all those all those active pieces
should Jack count for something Bishop
on b2 and the knight on d5 both the real
monster pieces just threatening rook age
one yeah I can take these six now not
sure if this is the easiest one they are
probably no no drawback apparent so yeah
maybe threaten route g6 taya the time
was getting low so I wanted to play rook
h8 no I haven't yet taken only five whoo
okay so i have to take now threatening
this at least ah stupid on know what is
stupid mistake i was somehow thinking
that i'm already I already have taken
down Wow
poo okay unfortunately it's still pretty
good c5 push up to D 426 not sure I'm
more 96 probably makes it easier
probably for the King to approach King
f7 though as a move
Jack it's not that promising ready now
if he takes a Jew I have four heads it's
really strong so where this is a mate
I'm Jack he cannot step up yeah that's
made only five shack wow what a stupid
blonde I am giving away the I was simply
having an hallucination there check when
I was a check to check when i was i was
taking their I was really thinking
there's I was thinking I was threatening
this simply here any any move wins of
course janet was simply thinking i have
i have the diagonal open I mean from
earlier it's really weird it's still
difficult to play for black that some
hard to tell where he went wrong around
here I think it gets better for white
again let us have a brief look at the
whole whole sequence IAM yeah i think
this this should be should be nice for
wide he has some weaknesses and i have
slightly better better activity and i
think this is a good plan pushing on the
Kings side an age 5 or this one is both
good check cheek you know the computer
approves them all that and gives me a
pretty clear advantage on the time Jack
now in tier white winter I was really
having this viet elucidation of the
bishop being on the open diagonal i am
otherwise a pretty good game thanks for
watching